national when you see the word rational
that means ratio and ratio when you
think of a ratio you think of comparing
two quantities like in a fractional form
and root what root means is that that's
a solution of the equation it's what
makes the equation equal to zero and
these are also the points where the
graph crosses the x-axis so that's the
roots okay they call these roots
solutions x-intercepts zeroes will all
mean the same thing and so the way we
find these rational roots is by taking
all the factors of the constant
sometimes we refer to that as P or
overall the factors of the leading
coefficient this number here in front so
all the factors of the constant meaning
all the numbers are divided and even
lead to 12 all the integers divided by
all the integers that dividing evenly 2
into this leading coefficient 2 so if
we're going to do that all the factors
of 12 are going to be plus or minus 1 2
3 4 6 and 12 and all the factors of the
leading coefficient would just be plus
or minus 1 plus or minus 2 so these are
all the numbers of divided and evenly to
the leading coefficient so now what you
can do is you can take any number in the
numerator divided by any number in the
denominator and come up with a possible
rational root so these aren't guaranteed
to be the roots but what it does is it
narrows down the possibilities that you
could try in order to find out you know
a root or a solution or zero of this
polynomial so you're narrowing down like
if I had to you know guess which number
would make this equal to zero it might
be awhile for me guessing I might try
and factor this and set the factors to
zero but I might not be easily factored
it might not be in a form that I
recognize and that's where the rational
root theorem comes in I can see this
isn't a quadratic it's a cubic so it's a
little bit more challenging to factor so
here's what we do we take the factors of
the constant over the factors of leading
coefficient if you want you can write
these out you could say like this is
going to be plus or minus 1 over 1 which
is 1 this is going to be 2 over 1 which
is 2 so these all could be positive or
negative 3 4
6:12 or it could be 1/2 okay so I'll
just slip in 1/2 right there okay or it
could be 2 over 1 which is 2 arrow to
have listed 2 over 2 which is 1 3 over 2
okay we don't have that one I'll put
that one in there 3 over 2 4 over 1 we
have that 4 over 2 is 2 we have that 6
over 2 is 3 6 over 1 we have that 12
over 2 which is 6 we have that so so
these are all the possible rational
roots now what we do to test them out is
we do synthetic division so let's let's
say we wanted to test to see if 6 was a
root what we do is we go over here and
we do our synthetic division to negative
12 22 and negative 12 and we do our
synthetic division so this is 1200 22
120 130 to 120 so this one didn't come
out to 0 so that means that 6 is not a
zero it's not a root of this polynomial
okay so cross that one off the list
let's try another one let's say we want
to try one okay so 2 negative 2 22
negative 12 those are our coefficients
we're doing a synthetic division 2 2 0 0
22 22 okay and this comes out to 10 so
oh I made a mistake because this is 12
okay let's do that again so this would
be negative 10 this would be negative 10
this would be 12 and then this would be
12 and this would be 0 okay so there we
go so that we have got 0 as a remainder
so that means that 1 is a zero okay it
is a root and what happens when you do
the synthetic division is this goes down
by one degree so originally it was a
cubic now we're gonna be down to a
quadratic so 2x squared minus 10x plus
12 now that it's in the quadratic we can
do the quadratic formula
to find the other zeros or we can factor
so here I'm just going to factor I'm
gonna factor out the two and here I can
factor this into two binomials X minus 3
and X minus 2 if I set these factors
equal to zero we get three or two okay
so we have our zeros one two and three
okay so what that means is you can write
this in factored form it's going to be
two okay that's that two right there
X minus three X minus two okay and then
one was a zero so X minus the zero is a
factor X minus the zero is a factor so
it's X minus one so this is our
polynomial here in factored form
you set the factor to zero you get the
the zeroes the x-intercepts and if we
wanted to graph this it's going to cross
here at one two three the leading
coefficient is positive so that tells us
it's going to go up to the right it's an
odd degree which tells it's going to go
the opposite way to the left so just
making a rough sketch here the graphs
gonna look something like that it's
going to cross at these points we have
the end behavior it's a quick way to get
a sketch of this polynomial without you
know taking it to the next level so this
is basically just a quick way to get a
graph finding the zeros using the
rational root theorem and go ahead and
review this video if you need to go
through it one more time and I'll see
you in the next video